say it i deserve it i deserve it again
i deserve it feels good doesn't it
street next door tells the story of a
very codependent relationship that spans
27 years marty markowitz and his sister
phyllis they've just lost their parents
he's very vulnerable and feels that the
walls are caving in on him
seeing how much stress her big brother
was under
phyllis recommended a therapist ike
at first dr ike is everything you would
hope a therapist would be a great
listener really helps him solve problems
the thing about obstacles they're either
stumbling blocks or stepping stones
they're kind of having an identity
crisis ike is feeling a lack of
fulfillment with being a therapist
and marty is really ill-equipped to deal
with the obstacles that are being thrown
his way you okay puppy yeah yeah having
one of my panic attacks it'll pass
ike helped him enormously at the
beginning then that relationship morphed
into something unhealthy welcome doctor
i starts to manipulate him he takes over
marty's hampton's house
what's the big deal they think it's my
place huh no who cares whose place it is
i agree
this doctor seems a little
unconventional huh but the thing is he
cares so much
it starts to get further away from
what's acceptable you know sometimes i
feel like i'm working on you but i don't
think you're working on you you promise
i'll work harder marty doesn't realize
how bad it is he's just thankful that
this therapist is in his corner i don't
trust him he's trying to help me phyllis
was toxic you did the right thing by
cutting her out of your life
by separating him from phyllis marty and
ike really become so intertwined which
is the heart of the story you're a
growing morty i mean this is all because
of you you should be proud of yourself
i'm proud of you i wanted the audience
to feel sort of seduced and charmed by
ike mrs martia's everything's gonna be
all right i'm not gonna let anyone use
you it's heartbreaking you go into it
thinking well that would never happen to
me i'd be impervious to the journey that
this guy went on
when you're in it you just think
differently it's very easy to believe
what we want to believe you know i'm
doing this for you
anyone at any moment feeling vulnerable
could go down this road trust is at the
very core of who i am i do trust you
[Music]